todo
[Música]
hola hoy en saints click la relatividad
especial
imaginemos una nave espacial al igual
que un planeta aislados en las
profundidades del universo
supongamos que la nave espacial se mueve
con respecto al planeta en una dirección
fija y con una velocidad constante
una de las primeras propiedades
fundamentales del universo es que en
esta situación es estrictamente
imposible saber si es la nave espacial
la que se mueve estando el planeta
inmóvil
o si es la nave espacial la que está
inmóvil mientras que el planeta se mueve
en la dirección opuesta
esto se conoce como el principio de la
relatividad sea cual sea el punto de
vista que se adopte cuando el movimiento
se produzca en línea recta con una
velocidad constante es tan válido
considerar que es la nave espacial como
el propio planeta el que se mueve
imaginemos ahora que un pasajero de la
nave espacial decide lanzar una pelota
hacia adelante
para él la pelota se mueve hacia
adelante con una determinada velocidad
esta velocidad corresponde simplemente
al impulso que se le ha dado a la pelota
pero si observamos la misma situación
desde el punto de vista del planeta la
pelota parece moverse más rápido pues a
su velocidad de impulsos se les suman la
de la propia nave espacial
lo curioso es que si ahora intentamos
hacer la misma experiencia con la luz
utilizando por ejemplo la luz de una
linterna vemos que sea cual sea el punto
de vista la velocidad de la luz sigue
siendo la misma independientemente de si
la miramos estando inmóviles o en
movimiento tanto si la iluminamos desde
un punto de fijo como si lo hacemos
desde uno movimiento siempre
observaremos que la luz se mueve con la
misma velocidad exacta decimos que dicha
velocidad de la luz es invariante la
velocidad de la luz es una constante
universal que subyace en la estructura
misma de nuestro universo
en nuestra vida cotidiana la velocidad
de la luz es excesiva para que podamos
percibir cualquier efecto de este
principio en un abrir y cerrar de ojos
un rayo de luz recorre 6 veces la
distancia entre parís y nueva york
sin embargo está sutil propiedad de la
luz provoca cambios drásticos en nuestra
forma de ver el mundo
en la relatividad especial un concepto
fundamental es que dos acontecimientos
pueden ocurrir simultáneamente para una
persona pero en momentos diferentes para
otra
para entenderlo imaginemos el siguiente
escenario
el pasajero la nave espacial sostiene
dos linternas una que apunta hacia atrás
y otra hacia adelante
su rol será encender las dos linternas
exactamente al mismo tiempo
a continuación observara en qué momento
los dos rayos de luz alcanzan los bordes
de la nave espacial
empezará por encender las dos linternas
a la vez
como desde su punto de vista la nave
espacial permanece inmóvil los rayos de
luz se propagaran por ambos costados de
la misma manera llegarán a los dos
extremos de la nave espacial al mismo
tiempo para el pasajero los dos
acontecimientos son simultáneos los dos
rayos de luz llegan a los dos extremos
de la nave espacial a la vez
pero veamos ahora esta misma situación
tal y como la percibe un observador en
la superficie del planeta
como la velocidad de la luz es una
constante cuando se enciendan las dos
linternas la luz se propagara con la
misma velocidad hacia ambos lados
pero al mismo tiempo la nave espacial se
mueve hacia adelante
el rayo de luz enviado hacia la
izquierda llegar a la parte trasera nave
espacial antes de que el rayo de luz de
la derecha llegue a la parte delantera
[Música]
desde este punto de vista los dos
acontecimientos no son simultáneos los
rayos de luz no llegan a los dos lados
de la nave espacial al mismo tiempo
para explicar esta paradoja debemos
dejar de lado nuestra concepción
intuitiva del tiempo
en la situación anterior si el rayo de
luz de la izquierda alcanza el borde de
la nave antes que el rayo de luz de la
derecha se debe en realidad a que la
parte trasera de la nave espacial está
ligeramente en el futuro en comparación
con su parte frontal
cuando es mediodía en el centro de nave
espacial puede que ya sea la una de la
tarde en su parte trasera mientras que
solo sea en las 11 de la mañana en su
parte delantera
desde el punto de vista del pasajero
dentro de la nave los relojes están
perfectamente sincronizados
es el hecho de observar desde un punto
de vista en movimiento lo que te
sincroniza la parte trasera y la parte
delantera de la nave entre sí
de una manera más general cuando un
objeto se mueve con una velocidad
extremadamente alta observamos que la
parte delantera al objeto se retrasa en
el tiempo con respecto a la parte
trasera
si pusiéramos por ejemplo a dos personas
de la misma edad observaríamos desde el
planeta que la persona que se encuentra
delante de la nave es ligeramente más
joven con respecto a la que se encuentra
atrás
una consecuencia directa de este
fenómeno es lo que llamamos la
contracción espacial
como vimos previamente cuando se observa
desde el planeta la parte trasera la
nave espacial está ligeramente en el
futuro pero como la nave espacial viaja
en el tiempo si la parte trasera la nave
está en el futuro también está
ligeramente avanzada con respecto a su
movimiento del mismo modo la parte
delantera está ligeramente retrasada con
respecto al movimiento de la nave
espacial la longitud global de la nave
se ve por tanto contraída en el sentido
de su velocidad
a velocidades usuales esta contracción
es mínima prácticamente imperceptible un
coche que se desplace a toda velocidad
por una autopista sólo se contraerá
alrededor de la longitud del núcleo de
un átomo
pero cuanto más nos acerquemos a la
velocidad de la luz más importante será
este fenómeno de contracción si nuestra
nave espacial pudiese viajar a un 85 por
ciento de la velocidad de la luz su
longitud se contraería a la mitad al 90
y 9.5 por ciento de la velocidad de la
luz su longitud constatada sería sólo
una décima parte de su longitud original
en esta situación vista desde el planeta
la nave espacial parecería
extremadamente encogida pero desde el
punto de vista al pasajero que está
dentro no es la nave espacial la que
está contraída sino el planeta ya que
desde su perspectiva es el planeta que
se mueve y no la nave espacial
finalmente una tercera consecuencia
directa de la imm varianza de la
velocidad de la luz es lo que llamamos
la dilatación del tiempo para entenderlo
mejor consideremos el siguiente
experimento
el pasajero el interior de la nave
espacial tomará una vez más una linterna
esta vez apuntando hacia el techo
en un momento dado encenderá la luz y
observara el tiempo que tarda el rayo de
luz en llegar al techo de la nave
una vez más el problema cambia si
decidimos observar la misma situación
desde el planeta
para el observador en el planeta tanto
la nave espacial como el pasajero que se
encuentra en su interior están en
movimiento así el haz de luz tendrá que
recorrer no sólo la altura del techo
sino también tendrá que viajar hacia la
derecha siguiendo el movimiento de la
nave espacial
desde este punto de vista el rayo de luz
debe recorrer una distancia mayor en
consecuencia al igual que se tarda más
en cruzar una carretera en diagonal que
por su ancho la luz tardará más en
llegar al techo de la nave espacial
para este observador que observa la
situación desde el planeta el rayo de
luz ha tardado más tiempo en llegar al
techo la nave espacial
por lo general este observador ver al
interior de la nave espacial
evolucionando a paso lento
si el pasajero de la nave decidiera
exponer su reloj desde el planeta
veríamos su funcionar en cámara lenta
en términos más generales cuando un
objeto se mueve extremadamente rápido en
comparación con nosotros vemos su parte
trasera y delantera de sincronizadas su
longitud contraída y su evolución en
cámara lenta
para resumir estos fenómenos centrémonos
en el caso concreto de los muones
partículas cósmicas penetran en la alta
atmósfera
estas partículas llenas de energía se
desintegran progresivamente hasta formar
otras partículas elementales que
llamamos muones
en condiciones normales estos mojones
tienen una vida extremadamente corta
desaparecen después de unos pocos
microsegundos
sin embargo cuando intentamos
detectarlos desde la superficie de la
tierra vemos que un gran número de estos
mojones aún consiguen llegar al suelo
esta situación paradójica puede
explicarse a partir de los fenómenos que
hemos visto previamente
dado que los jóvenes que caen hacia el
suelo pueden alcanzar velocidades
extremadamente altas cercanas al 90 y
9.5 por ciento de la velocidad de la luz
es necesario considerar la contracción
espacial así como la dilatación del
tiempo
por un lado empecemos por situarnos
desde el punto de vista de un mundo
para el mundo es la tierra y en
particular la atmósfera la que se mueve
muy rápidamente en su dirección
debido a la contracción espacial el
mover así una atmósfera comprimida mucho
más delgada y que por lo tanto tendrá
suficiente tiempo para atravesarla por
completo antes de desaparecer
en cambio si nos situamos desde el punto
de vista de un observador en la tierra
son los muones los que se mueven con una
velocidad extremadamente elevada debido
a la dilatación del tiempo veremos a los
muones como si evolucionasen en cámara
lenta y por lo tanto su tiempo de vida
nos parecerá mayor
los monjes tendrán tiempo de llegar a la
tierra mucho antes de desintegrarse
en resumen el simple hecho de que la
velocidad de la luz sea constante de
cinca da en algunas consecuencias
importantes en la forma como percibimos
el mundo cuando un objeto se mueve con
respecto a nosotros en línea recta y con
una velocidad sumamente elevada lo vemos
evolucionar en cámara lenta a la vez que
parece contraído en la dirección del
movimiento
esta descripción de la relatividad del
tiempo y del espacio en función del
movimiento de los objetos es lo que
llamamos relatividad especial nos enseña
que el tiempo y el espacio no son
absolutos que dos observadores pueden
potencialmente percibir los de forma
diferente
también desencadena un gran número de
efectos como el hecho de que es
estrictamente imposible superar la
velocidad de la luz ya que para
alcanzarla se necesitaría una cantidad
infinita de energía
sin embargo este modelo de relatividad
se denomina especial ya que sólo se
aplica en casos muy sencillos
principalmente para movimientos que se
producen en línea recta con una
velocidad constante la contracción
espacial y la dilatación del tiempo no
son adecuadas para describir otro tipo
de movimientos cambios de dirección
aceleraciones disminuciones de velocidad
o incluso rotaciones para ello será
necesario adoptar una teoría mucho más
completa que nos permita dar cuenta de
la atracción gravitatoria sobre la base
de una geometría distorsionada del
espacio y del tiempo se trata de la
teoría de la relatividad general que
abordaremos en el próximo vídeo
[Música]